it is not easy keeping the power on
during this high heat especially since
so many if not all are cranking the ac
on average southern nevada uses a lot
more of it this time of year i went to
one of nv energy's largest power plants
today to see how they keep us all cool
electricity
as the extreme heat ramps up we're using
a lot more of it to cool down we're on a
lot more these units during the summer
that means local power plants like this
have to work a little harder to keep up
that steam goes to the steam generator
to produce even more power fadia tala is
the operations manager of envy energy's
clark generating station each of these
units powers 10 600 homes he says this
plant which runs on natural gas and
steam turbines generates power to about
235
thousand homes we maintain those units
we keep them top notch to be operational
for the summer and that maintenance is
crucial as triple digits take over and
everyone cranks up their ac in fact the
team here spends the rest of the year
preparing for our hottest days we fork
out how much power we need for the
summer season and they say they always
have a backup when more electricity is
needed and we also
have power purchase agreements with
other
power plants to be able to support the
summer season so the next time you go to
turn down the thermostat just know these
generators are working overtime
to make sure we survive any hot weather
we see these next few months
we are told the steam turbines there get
their power from recycled gray water so
those are also water efficient you can
help conserve power at home as well we
do have tips to do that on our website
8newsnow.com